la pression s'accentue sur le
gouvernement alors que la situation
sanitaire se dégrade et que les effets
des fêtes de fin d'année commence à être
observés un nouveau conseil de défense
ainsi qu'un conseil des ministres se
sont tenues ce mercredi au terme de ces
réunions de l'exécutif le porte parole
du gouvernement est revenu sur
l'efficacité du couvre feu de 18h en
place dans certains départements
manifestement il y a un effet sur la
circulation du virus de l'avancement du
couvre-feu à 18 heures et ce qui nous a
été démontrée ce matin à l'appui de
données et de statistiques c'est que
dans les départements où le couvre-feu a
été avancée à 18h au tout début du mois
de janvier la circulation du virus est
moins importante que dans d'autres
départements français c'est-à-dire qu'il
croît moins vite alors que le premier
ministre s'exprimera ce jeudi plusieurs
possibilités pour renforcer des mesures
en place s'offrent au gouvernement
tout d'abord un couvre-feu à 18h
généralisé sur l'ensemble du territoire
la deuxième option coupe leur ait le
couvre feu généralisé à 18 heures un
confinement le week end
enfin la piste la moins probable mais
nos confinement général des français
le premier ministre a récemment indiqué
qu'il ne fallait pas exclure un
troisième confinement en dernier recours
quid également des écoles le taux de
positivité des tests chez les moins de
20 ans ayant augmenté la semaine
dernière la question de la fermeture des
établissements pourraient revenir sur le
tapis
dans le même temps le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy appelle l'exécutif à prendre
des décisions rapides notamment pour
freiner la propagation du variant
anglais si on ne fait rien si on ne
prend pas très rapidement des décisions
on aura une extension du variant anglais
on est dans une sorte de course de
vitesse entre d'une part l'apparition
inéluctable de ce variant anglais qui
peut nous conduire à des chiffres de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes touchées
si on se projette début avril et d'autre
part la capacité à vacciner les
personnes les plus fragiles nous sommes
dans cette course pour les trois mois
qui viennent extension du couvre-feu
fermeture des écoles propagation du
variant anglais dans l'hexagone ou
encore accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
le premier ministre jean castex tentera
de répondre à ces problématiques lors
d'une nouvelle conférence de presse
prévue ce jeudi à 18 heures